I'm Janet Rankin I'm the interim
director of the teaching and learning
lab here at MIT and for the past four
years I've been teaching five nine five
J it has a lot of other numbers but it's
teaching college-level science and
engineering well before I came to MIT I
was on the faculty at Brown University
and I taught in the engineering
department there and it was very
interesting to me how you could either
do a really good job teaching or not so
good a job teaching so I started to get
interested in some of the theory and and
some of the best practices associated
with teaching specifically teaching
engineering but teaching in general and
I worked in the teaching and learning
center at Brown for a while and so when
there was the opportunity to come here
and work at MIT in the teaching and
learning lab I thought it would be great
a great opportunity to come and work
with other scientists and engineers who
are also interested in in improving
teaching or using research-based best
practices in teaching